what's a quirky thing that you do want
said before filming it would surprise me
well you know sometimes syllabus I guess
a lot on set oh yeah because there's
something about like just being free and
like sometimes if you're like moving
around or dancing kind of making a fool
out of yourself in front of 100 people
and so if you do that off-camera then
it's easy to do it on camera so there's
a lot of times I kind of I'll just dance
just to release tension just to the
first line the production notes for this
film reads through keepers wife is a
film written and directed by women how
do you think starring in this film will
affect the future roles you take on as
an actress well if you look at my roles
that I've taken on it's always been
female characters that push against the
status quo and what society expects them
to be or to do with their lives that
something's very important to me I work
in an industry that doesn't necessarily
support female filmmakers Dickey Carl is
an incredible filmmaker and I think she
did such a beautiful job with this film
so I'm hoping that when people see this
film they won't be so afraid of the
female point of view the need for
diversity is such an important talking
point right now in Hollywood what are
discussions that you think should be
happening right now in the film industry
with diversity particularly with women
um I think that people need to push back
a little bit it's not enough to just say
like oh we need more female summit
because we need more movies from
multiple points of view you have to look
at yourself and if you're part of the
industry you're part of the problem and
so you need to ask yourself what can you
do to start a positive change and it
looks like you haven't allowed yourself
to be defined by playing a particular
role why is that the idea of femininity
has been redefined in modern days now
femininity is defined by the individual
so women can be powerful they can be
ambitious they can be strong they can be
leaders they can be soft courageous and
brave and compassionate and kind and
loving and emotional they can be many
things so the characters I play I want
to encompass that in many different
characters who are one or two of your
heroes if the stars align that you would
love to play on the big screen we don't
acknowledge women in history like we
acknowledge men in history and there's
so many incredible characters out there
Belva Lockwood who was the first woman
to run for president and she ran for
president before women even had the
right to vote and she got four thousand
votes which meant four thousand men
voted for her she's an incredible woman
history Gerry Cobb is an incredible
woman in history and incresed a very
talented pilot who part of the mercury
13 and thought to be included to become
an astronaut there's women everywhere we
look that have forged these paths that
we now tread on and I hope to unearth
these stories and to celebrate the
sacrifices they made and to acknowledge
them
you